hi Abraham how are you how's it going
days better than I deserve what's up
well I'm reaching out to you I've been
watching your show on YouTube for the
last few months and I mainly stumbled
upon you because I wanted to know a
little bit more about sticky situations
with financing cars me and my girlfriend
about a year ago had pretty decent jobs
and we decided we wanted to get a new
car and we made the mistake of financing
a vehicle more than what we could afford
fast forward to now and neither of us
have those jobs anymore
and she's just trying to pick up work
and I'm right now on unemployment so
we're just kind of trying to figure out
what the next step is for getting out of
this car or whether we pay it off or
what what we can really do how much do
you owe on the corner right now 23 20 mm
oh my goodness and what's it worth right
now it's probably 13 13 maybe 15 some
said are you look okay Kelly Blue Book
private sale or yeah yeah private sale
okay probably 15 then okay so you're
like hey and a hole already you bought
the car new fan yeah what kind of car
it's a Jeep Patriot 2017 mm-hmm okay
what field of work are you in that
you're unemployed in Portland Oregon
today there's such a labor shortage
there I'm shocked yet and found a job
yeah well right now
what I was doing as I was working it for
a solar company so I was doing solar
installation mm-hmm and unfortunately I
got let go so I'm hoping to get back
into that field and I'm working with a
few programs locally that are
apprenticeship programs that start you
working and then working towards being
an electrician and about four to five
years time is the apprenticeship paid on
that yeah essentially you have to have
about 8,000 hours to be
part of the program so as soon as you
get accepted you have to take a job with
whatever companies that are out there
that are hiring or else you can't
qualify for the friendship program yeah
okay so you'll get paid as an apprentice
during this time that is that is correct
it was something that was an opportunity
while I was just an installer um but I
didn't take it didn't step on it and
installers um though the work expenses
you super low because the turnover rate
is pretty quick it just really depends
on how busy installation seasons are
gotcha okay all right yeah cuz I mean
man I'd be doing something to make some
money especially when you got this mess
on your hands and she's you said she's
just picking up work so she's doing what
she right now works for a catering
company so she's trying to find
something a lot more permanent and we
got this next week we got a bunch of job
fair events that we're lining up and
pretty much take anything that can work
around our schedule that way we can not
just be stuck under one employer and be
able to maximize our budget
good yeah because I mean you your
schedule is pretty open right now you go
make some money
on the short term I mean like panic
money almost right we're gonna go crazy
just for a short period of time I'm not
suggesting the jobs you're picking up
but I would have like three jobs by the
end of the week doing something so that
I can get this get rid of stupid car but
you're gonna have to be able to pay it
down because I'm guessing your credit is
not gonna allow you to go borrow $8,000
yeah no definitely not we this was our
first vehicle and we have so we had no
credit history at all
so it's been able to build or cut it a
little bit but it in comparison to what
the amount of debt it is it's just well
I'm sure the others was ridiculous yeah
it's like something like 17 percent oh
god okay yeah
man you guys the bad news is you've
learned a harsh lesson the good news is
you learned it you learned it early in
life so you don't to make this mistake
ever again when you're 63 you'll be
going don't do that
yelling at some guy in his 20s right oh
man because you'll remember this pain
the rest of your life so yeah it's all
about in the answer to your question is
it's all about income and all about
short term income and long-term income
both to clear the debt to get the pet
debt paid down far enough to get the car
sold okay or get yourself in a position
you can borrow the difference from a
local credit union or somebody but I'm
guessing that's going to be very
difficult number one you're unemployed
number two you know you're you're don't
even credit to amount anything and I
suspect you're not gonna be able just
walk into a credit union in this
situation and borrow $8,000 I'd be
shocked if you can but if you can
scratch up $8,000 from anywhere that's
legal get it I mean and get out of this
car because you're getting hammered
every day on this thing and every time
you start the key you put the key in the
ignition and start it's like another
bomb goes off under the hood because I
mean it's costing you bazillions of
dollars minute by minute on this thing
with the numbers you're giving me they
just make me cringe the math is just
horrendous
but yeah the impulsive nough some
decision is a lesson you've it was a
harsh harsh lesson and I'm sorry you're
facing it but in my 20s I lost
everything because I was dumber than you
I mean I did dumb stuff so you know I
learned the lesson though never going
back never going back and that's the
only good part of this this equation for
you guys
so hey if you need some more help you
call me anytime it's what we're here for
thank you for joining